the Joe Rogan experience and then can he
go back to that to the agile lifestyle
and with and take some of that strength
depends on how big he gets you know like
if you were talking like strongman
strength those guys are not known for
their agility right they're giant you
know there's there's a trade-off for
sure
there's a power trade-off you know
that's one of the things that's so
terrifying about Francis and gah know is
that he's 270 pounds cuts down to 265
but he moves like a panther right it's
like he's not missing anything like you
know I mean he's got ridiculous power
but he's also fast as [ __ ] like that
left hook that he hit over him with it's
like Jesus that's like a welterweights
left hook fast as [ __ ] but he's hitting
you like a nuclear weapon it's just a
different kind of power on his punches a
different kind of power in his body but
he also has the ability to move fast
like a smaller person most of the time
when you get a really powerful person
there's some sort of compromise it has
to be me right and but what if you take
what happens when a guy like Francis in
Ghana you develop his wrestling so that
it's like a Cain Velasquez could you
though at 33 like that's that's the
problem yeah like you know in how much
time does he not like to wrestle because
that was the word that I had heard is
that he wasn't doing any groundwork it
was very little groundwork being done
they were just trying to keep the fight
standing the problem with that is you
can't just do what you like to do you
you can't just do what you're awesome at
he's already awesome at putting people
in another dimension yeah I mean he hits
harder than anybody I've ever seen I've
never seen anybody that hits as hard as
Francis and gone oh and that's that
power cube thing shows it I mean he got
the highest registered punch Tyrone
Spong was number two his punch was
something like 10,000 pounds more power
or more than then Tyrone spawns which is
crazy he's a magician be allowed to hit
people he's a monster
he's so powerful but it's like all
things balanced out right like steep a
just said yeah you're powerful for about
five minutes yeah and I'm not gonna be
there for those five minutes top
and I'll be over here and I'll be
ducking and getting the [ __ ] away from
you hate it took a few it takes a guy
likes deep a that can is smart and fight
smart and knows the game like knows like
you can't keep this up but Kane be able
to do the same thing them you'd expect
so Aaron Cain young Cain for sure like
the cane to fought Cheick Kongo the Cain
have fought Ben Rothwell that cane Jesus
Christ that Cain could have done that to
anybody but I think what you deal with
with Cain was like a mental strength
that no one's body can hold up to yeah
you know I mean like he just drove
forward with so much tenacity that his
body is like tires are flying off and
bolts are breaking and there's just too
much strength in the mind
[Applause]